our week-long celebration of Mother's
Day continues tonight LL Cool J wants
you to meet his mom Andreea and she
shared some memories with the shelter
that are so precious and perhaps well a
little bit embarrassing I love more than
anything oh yeah is this little kid is
that cutie I'm just glad my eyes
straightened out as I I look like I was
looking everywhere huh
look I got Julia mom was a fox that was
I think he was toilet-training
where do I go from love that this is the
woman who can full-on embarrass ll by
opening up the family photo album and
showing us his growing pains this was
once Todd became LL we was just playing
around and taking pictures that was a
nice when he discovered jewelry yeah do
you ever call him LL or is it strictly
Todd I might tease him and say oh well
with something but no it's Todd he's LL
Cool J that's his job
when did you realize the ladies love
cool James the girls like toured but he
was bashful you didn't like really yes
thanks for that I remember that I'm like
just bad report card or something she
said you know Todd girls don't like
dummies Andra has always been a straight
shooter even as a single mom raising ll
in Queens she actually binge watches his
show in CIS LA and she loves her some
lip sync battle just like the rest of us
but what she loves most about her son is
the fact that he's a devoted father to
his four kids and husband to wife Simone
we married in 1995 he's a good dad he
always is involved he tries to get to
all of his children's activities and
everything
happy Mother's Day mine no I love you I
appreciate you and uh you know checks in
the mail
I know me too I love the energy between
them it was really hilarious
and by the way later that night we all
went to see Hamilton the musical and I
asked ll during the play like so would
you ever want to do a musical and he
said it surprised me absolutely
can you imagine also you wrote LLS
coattails into Hamilton okay uh yeah
that's what I took away